[Music]
surprise firings sci-fi callbacks and a
case of willday won't they that was very
different in real life even if it looked
like love on screen things weren't
always so smooth on the hit show Castle
between 1986 and 1988 screenwriter Tom
straw got his start writing a handful of
episodes of the NBC sitcom night court
before becoming an occasional writer on
Nurse Jackie and a regular contributor
on The Late Late Show with Craig
Ferguson staff in 2006. however in 2007
straw published his first novel the
trigger episode about a Pulitzer
prize-winning photojournalist who
becomes a member of the Hollywood
Paparazzi two years later ABC debuted
the popular crime series Castle which
stars Nathan fillian as Richard Castle a
mystery author police consultant and
private investigator in Castle the Title
Character writes a book series about
private investigators Derek storm and
Nikki Heat the latter of whom is based
on Castle's in-show partner Kate Beckett
played by Stana Katic in real life
Castle's books exist ranging from heat
wave in 2009 to heat storm in 2017. of
course Richard Castle isn't a real
author and instead straw assumed riding
duties under the show inspired pen name
as a way of bringing Castle's Persona to
life off-screen in many ways a character
of Kate Beckett was as essential to the
successes of Castle as Richard Castle
himself so after putting Nathan billion
in the titular role Andrew W Marlow and
Company then sought out as co-star and
on-screen love interest Marlo told The
Hollywood Reporter that catech along
with over 120 other actresses read with
Fillion before he and the rest of the
producers decided on her for the role
Marlow added when Stana walked in and
they started saying the words it became
more electric we had our fingers crossed
that we had captured lightning in a
bottle
I told you I have nothing did I say you
could talk did someone give you
permission to open your sorry little
mouth no it's hard to imagine anyone
else in the role of Beckett and katic's
on-screen chemistry with Billy and was
Immaculate warm and the Heart of Castle
altogether this is especially true in
the early Seasons before an off-screen
Feud would drive a wedge between them
it's easy to predict that had season 9
moved forward without catache fans would
not have reacted kindly it's not
uncommon for co-stars to also be wet
acting Partners such as David Tennant
and Georgia Moffitt from Doctor Who Anna
Paquin and Stephen Moyer from True Blood
as well as Alexis Bledel and Vincent
kurthheiser from Mad Men to name a few
we're all married couples in real life
and Castle Sheamus Dever and Juliana
Dever who play detective Kevin Ryan and
Jenny Ryan respectively were able to
one-up everyone else by being a married
couple both on screen and off their
on-screen characters even have a
daughter in the series named Sarah Grace
who was born after Ryan and Esposito
narrowly escaped death in the season 6
episode Under Fire while viewers were
grappling with Beckett and Castle's
possible romance across all eight
seasons the Ryan's provided a long
lasting Foundation of consistency
throughout the series Castle was not
immune to to its highs and lows but one
of the show's most consistent and
brightest Parts was always Jenny and
Kevin's relationship with each other and
their eventual Parenthood to Sarah Grace
only helped to solidify their bond and
make them an even more important pillar
of the show before he became Richard
Castle in 2009 Nathan Fillion won the
hearts of millions in the Beloved cult
favorite Fox series Firefly in 2002. in
the show he played Malcolm Reynolds a
space cowboy and captain of the ship's
Serenity the series has a legacy as one
of the best single season TV shows of
all time and phillian has even revived a
tongue-in-cheek version of Reynolds for
10 episodes of Netflix's Big Mouth
Series this was the role of a lifetime
though castle and Firefly are very
different shows the former pays multiple
tributes to the latter as redditors have
studiously documented and Castle's home
viewers can find Firefly props
everywhere Castle dressed as a space
cowboy for Halloween one year and catch
phrases from the cold hit have been
featured in episodes of Castle hello
shot Castle
I was aiming for his head
still one of the most explicit and
noticeable homages to Firefly and its
beloved ship came on a spa mentioned in
the series was named Serenity this gag
was capped off with a near complete
deadpan stare at the camera from the
former space Captain himself while
Firefly remains civilian's most adored
performance its castle that made him a
household name in Castle the show
maintained a strong consistent roster of
actors and actresses throughout its
eight season run major characters rarely
laughed and supporting roles are in the
space to add depth to their arcs still
only three actors were featured in all
173 episodes of Castle from 2009 to
2016. of course as the title character
Fillion's inclusion on that list comes
as no surprise however supporting actors
John huertas who plays Esposito and
Sheamus Deborah who plays Detective Ryan
also appear in every episode The Stana
Katic Tamela Jones Susan Sullivan and
Molly C Quinn are all credited on 173
episodes the actresses did not actually
appear in every entry across its eight
years despite the narrative's ups and
downs in the show's shifting critic
scores Kessel always kept its key
players in the game Castle's name is one
of great distinction even if you're
unfamiliar with the show Fillion made
his character one that avoided being
pigeonholed into only the show's fandom
much like he did with Mal and Firefly
however Castle wasn't born Richard
Castle before he was a best-selling
author or a consultant to the 12th
Precinct Castle was known as Richard
Rogers the son of Actress Martha Rogers
and a CIA agent known only as Jackson
hunt while there was never a full
explanation as to why he changed his
name the switch is acknowledged at least
once in the season 3 episode he's dead
she's dead Kate expresses some confusion
when Castle reminds her that his middle
name is Alexander which she always
thought was Edgar no I changed my middle
name to Edgar for Edgar Allan Poe back
when I changed my last name to Castle my
given name is Richard Alexander Rogers
when on screen together Philly and Katic
are two romantically involved characters
who play the will they won't they card
to an extreme before they get married in
season seven off-screen however fillian
and Katic could barely stand to act in
scenes together according to an
exclusive US Weekly report an Insider
linked to Castle revealed that the
showrunners made billion and Katic
attend couples counseling together
katic's Representatives ultimately
denied the allegations after season 8 in
2016 Katic was not approached by
production about reprising her role as
Beckett soon after ABC canceled the show
altogether according to an Entertainment
Weekly interview in 2018 katik explained
I'm actually still not clear on the
thought process behind the way that it
went down it hurts and it was a harsh
ending it's unlikely that the full story
will ever be revealed about what catech
and billions apparent Feud entailed but
reports of Cadet crying in her trailer
and a source claiming to US Weekly that
she and Fillion hated each other paint a
pretty clear picture before creating
Castle in 2009 Andrew W Marlow was a
scriptwriter in Hollywood he penned Air
Force One starring Harrison Ford in 1997
end of days starring Arnold
Schwarzenegger in 1999 and Hollow Man
starring Kevin Bacon in 2000 Air Force
One was a box office Smash and received
a positive critical reception all end of
days in Hollow Man both made money upon
release but currently hold negative
Rotten Tomatoes scores when Marlo made
the transition to network television
Castle was his first credit which he
created wrote an executive produced the
show became a resounding success
consistently reaching millions of
viewers every season and earning praise
from critics after season 7 concluded in
2015 however Marlow exited the program
along with his wife Terry Miller who
served as a co-writer and co-producer
following their departure Castle
struggled to maintain its fan base and
according to the audience score on
Rotten Tomatoes its eighth season was
considered the worst in the series
after a subpar season 8 that saw
viewership reach an all-time low
deadline reported that the possibility
of ABC not renewing castle for a ninth
season loomed over the heads of its
showrunners according to the Hollywood
Reporter along with Stana Katic being
fired from the show if it were to
continue Penny Johnson Gerald who plays
Captain Victoria Gates and Tamala Jones
who plays Lanny Parrish were also not
invited back for the hypothetical ninth
season even though the show was mixed
after season 8 the way production
severed ties with some of its most
beloved cast members left a sour taste
in viewers mouths upon learning that her
character would not be returning Johnson
Gerald tweeted her sorrow writing to my
castle fans around the world as of late
yesterday I am surprised and saddened to
learn that I will no longer be a part of
the castle family thank you all for your
support and love Jones's acting was
actually announced before season 8 ended
much to her dismay because I thought you
know let the fans get through the season
and then announce but when it came out I
was very much aware there's no doubt
that Katic Johnson Gerald and Jones's
departures would have cast a dark shadow
on season 9 had it been made the three
women were integral parts of the show
and the showrunner's decision to write
out their characters before ABC canceled
Castle remains a low point in the series
history Tamala Jones situation didn't
just surprise fans as the rest of the
cast had not been informed by production
that their co-stars would not be
returning for season 9 if it were to
happen Esposito actor John huertas had
signed on to return in season 9 but did
not learn at the departures of Jones
Katic and Johnson Gerald until it made
waves on social media the actor even
confirmed it himself announcing his
shock and dismay at the news on Twitter
despite where it is obvious frustrations
it's unclear whether or not the
production's handling of cast firings
played any role in the show's quick
demise it appears though that a rift
between the showrunners the network and
the cast could have been imminent had
they proceeded with season 9. Andrew W
Marlow's departure after season 7 draws
no immediate links to the decline in
quality that was seen during the final
season of Castle however Marlo couldn't
keep his opinions locked away once the
story he created took a divisive detour
in season 8. in 2016 Marlo tweeted what
appears to be his disapproval of how a
final season of Castle carried on which
included Beckett electing to take a
break from her relationship with Castle
the couple spends most of the final
season separated which goes against the
vision Marlow had started seven years
prior the Creator wrote on Twitter
heartbroken there are no words though
the show ends with castle and Beckett
depicted in a happily ever after
scenario according to Entertainment
Weekly producers filmed a different
ending in which the couple is still
separated but in a cliffhanger that left
both of their Fates up in the air Castle
found itself with a cast romance drawing
similarities to another procedural drama
on Fox the show Bones featured a
protagonist couple Brennan and booth
that was reminiscent of Castle and
Beckett's due to them being
crime-solving co-workers with a budding
love what bones did that castle failed
to do was give their protagonist romance
space to grow after marriage the build
up was worth it on the former since
Brandon and Booth would marry in season
9 and have three more seasons to
capitalize on their togetherness and
become even more layered as characters
than they already were and Castle
however castle and Beckett's marriage
was on the rocks by the series N this
dissolution was likely in part R2 to
Nathan Philly and stanic katic's ongoing
Strife behind the scenes beyond that
though a show built on the back of its
two main characters and their shared
romance is unlikely to survive once
those ties are severed in some way
[Music]